WHOEVER PREDICTED THAT THE
WORLD OF POLITICS WOULD GET
LESS ABSURD ONCE DONALD TRUMP
LEFT OFFICE DIDN'T COUNT ON
HAVING A CONSPIRACY THEORIST
WHO BLAMED WILDFIRES ON A
JEWISH SPACE LASER AND A
SECOND AMENDMENT LOVING GUN
THEMED RESTAURANT OWNER WHO
DOESN'T REALIZE THAT AMENDING
CHANGED IT DUKING IT OUT FOR
REPUBLICAN FRESHMAN OF THE
YEAR IN THE HOUSE. THAT'S NOT
A GOOD THING. THEY DIDN'T
COUNT ON MITCH MCCONNELL
LEARNING THE HARD WAY THAT
WHAT CITIZENS UNITED CREATES
THIS WELL IT CAN ALSO TAKE
IN VERY EXPLICIT IN SAYING
THAT CORPORATIS ARE PEOPLE
ONLY WHEN THEY'RE WRITING BIG
CHECKS TO REPUBLICANS.
REALLY? THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
IF OUR RUNNING A MAJOR
CORPORATION, I'D STAY OUT OF
POLITICS. I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS.
SHUT UP, AND GIVE ME ALL YOUR
MONEY MCCONNELL TRIED TO
CLARIFY TODAY BY PRETTY MUCH
REPEATING WHAT HE SAID AND
INSULTING CORPORATION. SO
THAT'S GOING WELL FOR HIM AND
THE GOP AND THE 2021 WILL BE
MORE BORING FOLKS. ALSO
DIDN'T COUNT ON CONGRESSMAN
MATT GAETZ ANY PART OF MATT
GAETZ THE FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN
AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER IS
THE SUBJECT OF A FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION OVER VIOLATING
SEX TRAFFICKING LAW SOMETHING
HE DENIES AND YET NOW WE'VE
LEARNED THAT HE'S SET TO BE
THE KEYNOTE SPEAKER AT WAIT
FOR IT A WOMEN.
OR AMERICA CONFERENCE
THAT'S A CONSERVATIVE WOMEN'S
GROUP IN CASE YOU WERE
WONDERING AND YES THE VENUE
WHATEVER TO A ROOM FULL OF
BECAUSE OF COURSE IT IS. HOW
CAN GATES IS SPEECH BE HELD
ANYWHERE ELSE, PERHAPS IT
WASN'T JUST A TRUMP
PRESIDENCY THAT LOOKED LIKE
AN EPISODE OF VEEP PERHAPS.
IT'S RIGHT WING AMERICAN
POLITICS AS A WHOLE THESE
DAYS JOINING ME NOW IS THE
PERFECT PERSON TO TALK ABOUT
EXECUTIVE PRODUCER OF VEEP
DAVID. THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING BACK ON.
SHOW IT'S BEEN A WHILE. LET
ME ASK YOU THIS. WHAT WAS
YOUR PREDICTION FOR THE
ABSURDITY QUOTIENT OF 2021
POLITICAL NEWS. ONCE TRUMP
LEFT OFFICE. DID YOU THINK
WILL GET BACK TO NORMAL IN
2021 ON THE JOE BIDEN OR DID
YOU EXPECT IT TO CARRY ON
I WAS DEFINITELY EXPECTING
MORE NORMAL. I WAS HONESTLY
AND I DO FEEL LIKE WE HAD
LIKE A MONTH OFF THEY KIND OF
GAVE US A MONTH AND THEN IT'S
JUST BACK THERE BITS BACK TO
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO FORMALLY
ENDORSE WHOEVER ON THE PLANET
THEY HAVE MY ENDORSEMENT. I .
JUST WANT TO I WATCHED YOUR
LAST SEGMENT AND WHOEVER DUCK
QUOTE MINE COMP HAS MY
ENDORSEMENT. I MEAN AGAIN,
FORWARD TO IT AGAIN. IT'S A
VERY HIGH BAR TO MEET ISN'T
IT DAVID? IT'S A VERY HIGH
BAR IF YOU DON'T QUOTE MY
KAMPF GO FOR THE SENATE IN
ALABAMA. IT'S MY ONLY PIECE
OF ADVICE. DON'T QUOTE
MINECART. OH, I ACCIDENTALLY
QUOTED MY INCOME. I MEAN IT
JUST YEAH. YEAH
RIGHT TELL US ABOUT YOUR NEW
SHOW DAVID. TELL US ABOUT
YOUR NEW SHOW THE WHITE HOUSE
HARRELSON IS E HOWARD HUNT
AND JUSTIN THROUGH HIS G
GORDON LIDDY WHO DIED LAST
WEEK, OF COURSE. WHAT IS THAT
ALL ABOUT REMIND US?
IT'S BASICALLY IT'S A
MINISERIES FOR HBO. THAT'S
BASICALLY GOING TO KIND OF
LOOK AT WATERGATE THROUGH THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE PLUMBERS
WHO YOU KNOW DID THE BREAK-IN
HUNT AND LIDDY AND REALLY IN
SOME WAYS. IT'S SORT OF IN
THOSE EARLY DAYS OF THE DARE.
SAY THE CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENT. IT'S THE BIRTH OF
THE TRUE BELIEVERS THE TRUE
BELIEVERS THAT ALMOST KIND OF,
YOU KNOW, JUST ARE WILLING
TO SORT OF ALMOST BURN THE
OF THIS, YOU KNOW THIS SORT
OF IN
TO ME INSANE JUST
ADVOCACY OF WHAT THEY THINK
IS RIGHT AND WHY YOU'RE WRONG
THAT'S I THINK WHAT'S AGAIN,
INTERESTING ABOUT AND WE'RE
STARTING ON THE SORT OF
PRE-PRODUCTION. WE'RE GOING
TO HOPEFULLY START SHOOTING
IN MAY. SO WE'RE KIND OF JUST
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE IT. YOU'RE
DIRECTING IT. OBVIOUSLY AS
PRODUCTION, YOU'VE IMMERSED
YOURSELF. I'M ASSUMING IN
THAT NIXONIAN WORLD. A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE COMPARED NIXON
AND TRUMP WHO'S MORE CROOKED.
WILL CORRUPT IN YOUR VIEW.
I'M IN MY VIEW AND I TRULY
BELIEVE IN HISTORY WHEN
WE GET A LITTLE FURTHER AND
WE WRITE ABOUT IT. YOU KNOW,
THERE'S THAT MOMENT WHERE
EVEN NIXON REALIZED HE HAD TO
RESIGN THAT. THAT JUST
DOESN'T EXIST FOR TRUMP THE
CORRUPTION THE FAMILY THE
MONEY HIS THE CHILDREN THE THE
PARDONS. I JUST ALL OF THOSE
THINGS THE JUST THE HOTEL
JUST LIKE NO POINTED NIXON
EVER OPEN A RESTAURANT IN DC
AND MAKE PEOPLE GO TO IT. YOU
KNOW WHAT? I MEAN? IT'S JUST
A WHOLE OTHER LEVEL TEST THAT
BE SURE THE FRAMERS NEVER
COUNTED ON. IT'S JUST A VERY
DIFFERENT THING THAT I AGAIN
. I DO THINK WE NEED A LITTLE
DISTANCE BUT THE THE FURTHER
WE GET THE WORSE IT WILL SEE
IS WHAT I HONESTLY BELIEVE
ABOUT THESE TRUMP YEARS.
SORRY KIDS, BUT I DO THINK
WHAT'S REALLY INTERESTING IS
LOOKING BACK ON NIXON AND
AGAIN THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
IT DOESN'T TRUMP BECOMES
LESS SHOCKING. THIS HAS BEEN
DIDN'T COME OUT OF NOWHERE.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON. I
GUESS AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED
SINCE LYNDON JOHNSON SIGNED
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT. THAT'S
THAT'S THE HONEST ANSWER
THERE IS A MIST A HARD LINE
OF RACISM THAT JUST COLORS
ALL OF THIS AND GETS US TO
TRUMP AND I'M SORRY TO SAY
THE MODERN REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND I DO REALLY FEEL THAT WAY
AND BY LOOKING BACK
BACKWARDS YOU YOU START TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW.
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT COME TO
MIND AS YOU WERE JUST
SPEAKING THERE. I MEAN WE
TALKED ABOUT MO BROOKS IN IN
THE EARLIER SEGMENT. WE
TALKED ABOUT DONALD TRUMP. WE
TALK ABOUT MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREEN. I MEAN RICHARD NIXON
FOR ALL HIS MANY FLAWS SINS
AND CRIMES WAS A SMART GUY
WAS AN INTELLIGENT PERSON. NO
ONE EVER QUESTIONED HIS
INTELLECT OR HIS GRASP OF
POLITICS. THESE PEOPLE ARE ON
A DIFFERENT LEVEL LEVEL OF
KIND OF IGNORANCE AND
CONSPIRACIES. MMM. AND THE
A GOOD POINT THAT NIXON SUCH
AGREED GET AT THE END TO GIVE
IT UP WHEREAS TRUMP IS STILL
THE ELECTION WAS MENT SAYING
STOLEN SO PRETTY
EASTER STATEMENTS WHICH ARE
ALL ABOUT HOW THE ELECTION
WAS STOLEN FROM HIM, BY THE
WAY, HAPPY EASTER WHICH
REMINDS US JUST HOW OFF THE
YOU KNOW, HOW IN A DIFFERENT
PLANET DONALD TRUMP IS YEAH,
LET'S ALSO POINT OUT THAT HE
IS PUTTING OUT STATEMENTS. I
MEAN ALL ALONG HE'S BEEN
PUTTING OUT STATEMENTS ABOUT
HOW EITHER NOW OBVIOUSLY IT'S
THEY STOLE THE ELECTION. BUT
BEFORE THE ELECTION THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO STEAL THE
ELECTION AND IN THOSE EARLIER
STATEMENTS ABOUT HOW THE
DEMOCRATS WERE GOING TO STEAL
ACTION, THEY WERE TAKING
PEOPLE'S CREDIT CARD NUMBERS
BANK ACCOUNT INFORMATION AND
EMPTYING THEIR OWN QUARTERS
OF STOCK. WE'RE GOING TO NAME
STEAL FROM YOU AND NOT TELL
YOU WHILE WE'RE ACCUSING
OTHER PEOPLE OF STEALING AND
THAT'S THE GRAND GRIFT OF
THIS HIGHER THING THAT JUST
THROWS IT IN AND HAS A OTHER
ON NIXON LEVEL. YEAH, AND
AGAIN IT JUST YOU KNOW, THESE
ME THROWN OUT OF THE VIPERS
KEEP COMING BACK TO THAT VERY
FUNNY WAY. WELL, IT'S
SOMETHING IT'S SOMETHING YOU
WOULD I TALK TO. MY REMEMBER.
YOU CAME ON THE SHOW LAST
TIME THIS IDEA THAT JUST YOU
WOULD NOT YOU KNOW, YOU CAME
UP WITH THE GATE STORYLINE
THE TRUMP THIS NEW YORK TIMES
DURING ABOUT TRUMP STEALING
MONEY FROM VOTERS, YOU KNOW,
LAUGHED OUT OF A WRITING ROOM
YOU AND JULIA LOUIS-DREYFUS
TRIED TO PLAY UP THE VENUS OF
TRUMP AT THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION LAST
SUMMER WHICH JULIA HOSTED THE
NEW BOOK BY JONATHAN ALLEN?
AND AMY POND AS THEY DIDN'T
UM, YOU KNOW AGAIN THEY
I GUESS THEY YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY THEY WERE SOMEWHAT
CONCERNED. AND AGAIN, THIS IS
I THINK SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW HAPPENS WITH DEMOCRATS A
LOT LIKE A LOT AND YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS EARLIER
WITH YOU KNOW, YOU TALK ABOUT
THE GAL FRANKEN AND STUFF
WHERE WE HOLD OURSELVES TO A
THINK THEIR CONCEPT WAS IF WE
BRING WE ATTACK DONALD TRUMP
FOR HIS GENERAL MENTAL
UNFITNESS THAT THEY'RE
SOMEHOW GOING TO THEN TURN
AROUND AND DO IT TO JOE BIDEN.
AND BECAUSE IF WE DON'T DO IT,
THEY WON'T AND OF COURSE
THEY DO IT NO MATTER WHAT AND
MY POINT THE TIME WAS EXACTLY
LET'S JUST DO IT FIRST. LET'S
JUST DO IT FIRST. WHAT ARE WE
WAITING FOR? AND OBVIOUSLY,
YOU KNOW, IT SEEMS IN SOME
WAYS LIKE DURING THE ENTIRE
CERTAINLY DURING HIS YOU KNOW,
EVERY TIME JOE BIDEN SPEAKS.
OF I THINK SOMETIMES LIKE I T
GUESS REPUBLICAN EXPECTATION
OF WAIT TILL HE MESSES UP.
LET'S WATCH TO SEE HOW
BIDEN MESSES UP AND HE
DOESN'T MESS UP AND YET THEY
NEVER SEE WHAT THEIR OWN
GUIDE DOES AS HE WHETHER IT'S
WRONG NAME THROWS TOILET E
PAPER LOOKS AT AN ECLIPSE,
YOU KNOW PICK PICK YOUR
POISON, BUT IT'S YOU KNOW
ATTACK ATTACK AND WHAT I
LOVED ABOUT JULIA HOSTING THE
NIGHT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTION.
IT'S WE'RE GOING TO ATTACK
BACK. THAT'S WHY YOU HIRE
JULIA LOUIS-DREYFUS TO HOST
THE NIGHT OF YOUR CONVENTION
TO ATTACK BACK A LITTLE BIT.
SO THAT'S THAT WAS MY
PRISONER. VERY GOOD POINT LA
LAST QUICK QUESTION BEFORE WE
RUN OUT OF TIME 30 SECONDS
LEFT. JOE BIDEN SNL IS NOW IN
ITS 3RD BIDEN IMPERSONATOR
SOMETHING ABOUT BUYING THAT'S
BIDEN GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY.
EVEN IF IT'S BAD FOR COMEDY
AND SATIRE.
I MEAN, I LOVE BORING BIDEN.
OFFENSE TO SNL. ALL I CAN SAY
IS CHECK OUT DANA CARVEY.
HE'S BY AN IMPRESSION. IT'S
REALLY REALLY REALLY GOOD.
IS REALLY GOOD AND IT SHOWS
THE WAY TO WHAT THAT
IMPRESSION SHOULD BE COULD BE.
IT'S REALLY QUITE GOOD. YEAH.
NO, I'VE SEEN AND I WOULD
SECOND THAT DAVID MANDEL.
HAVE TO LEAVE IT THERE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING ME
TODAY. I APPRECIATE IT.